Welcome everyone to the 20 21 t
mobile home run derby where we
have elements and the
environment in the event perhaps
the most anticipated homerun
derby ever.
All of that has to do with the
headliner.
Who is Shohei Ohtani.
Then you wonder about the local
kid trever story how he's going
to do all part of what makes
this such an unforgettable
night.
Mancini will step in.
Twenty nine years old.
Well he's found the happy zone.
Mancini is locked in right now
the number to ten.
He has done a wonderful job.
Catching everything out in
front.
You need to continue to throw
the pitches down and then write
down trees absolute.
Absolutely.
What a start to this.
Twenty twenty one t mobile home
run derby.
A cancer survivor.
Listen to the ovation driven
story 11 home runs.
The fans.
He talked about the energy he
draw from them talking about a
Semien the elevation.
And he really believes his
ballpark is better suited for
right handed hitters on the
winning.
He's my boy.
We're on a great show for the
home fans.
The fans deserve it and he's got
more left in him.
Going to be all right.
He's a dead hitter right now.
Home run total four story twenty
eight.
Alonzo the twenty nineteen
champion after he won.
Not that he showed up and drove
in a couple of runs in the
All-Star Game the next day.
The first rookie multiple RB
eyes and an all star game.
But he lives for the lives for
it.
Let's not forget the polar bear
who just keeps ripping off.
That's gone in a big way.
And he goes to the crowd to get
them involved.
What a round.
Here's a guy who you remember of
course from his rookie
performance in the twenty
nineteen postseason drum solo
Urquidy.
Twenty five.
Twenty five is a number that
will put a lot of pressure on
Oton.
And again twenty two for Warren
Soto.
You just don't know what the
Ohtani experience is going to be
like.
This is going to be special
right now and that's what a lot
of people waited for.
And there was a level of
amazement with O'Day Tatis from
his ear you know question just
Shohei Ohtani just apparently
got words of wisdom from his
angel teammate Mike Trout.
That's it right there.
That ties it now with it he
made.
With three in a row I don't
think that's going to go.
We have our first swing off of
the twenty twenty one t mobile
home run derby and Sodo will set
the bar for Ohtani and Jose
Altuve gas right now.
So there's Luzardo has an
advantage.
He had sat down waited in the
meantime.
So Tonnie the gas.
Let's see if that works for one
great effort from the twenty two
year olds.
Now it's Ohtani or join the
Angels in December of twenty.
Seventeen is a twenty three year
old.
Here he goes and Shohei Ohtani.
We're going to have a little
swing off three swings Junior
now down Soto just went three
for three.
Can't do better than that.
Three swings.
They've only got Albies.
I think everybody feels the
tension in this ballpark and
that will do it.
One Soto.
Three perfect Swedes to feed so
hey how tiny about three Mazzini
right now coming up here's the
tiny one from the next one We'll
move him on and that's a shot to
center at that.
He Alonzo the Mets fans adore
him Treinen.
Of seismic Gleyber Torres in
Freeman Urquidy who was in and
out of the hospital and
chemotherapy with stage three
cancer Bobby Orr Dustin Garneau.
That very few humans can do on
the planet.
What an effort Freddie Freeman
Cindy Anthony spends.
It's putting up twenty two is
the number one good right now so
far 60 percent of the pitches
he's seen have left the ballpark
in this round.
He said again recently.
We're going to take it home
again.
I had a fun time winning.
I'm going to win again.
Six wins it and now it's five
that will win it.
Another massive shot from Alonzo
for to win it like a countdown
three to win it.
To to win it he's not missing.
One more to win it as Alonzo
comes out of the timeout.
What a finish.
Alonzo defends his title the
twenty twenty one Derby champion
put the belt on again won a
double header for giving him the
trophy Pollock and Alonzo.
He made that look easy.
Spin it to win it Derby
champion.